Tell me something.
You can go
anywhere you want.
Any timeline any universe
why do you want to stay
fight to save this one
Are you in?
Welcome back, everyone.
It's Charlie.
A first look at the main
villain of the Flash
movie was just released,
so we'll break it all down.
It changes
some of the original Reverse-Flash
storyline
that they're adapting for the movie
because they're doing
a version of Flashpoint
All explain,
but it combines a lot of Easter eggs.
That also includes some easter eggs
for the DCTV Grant Gustin Flash
If you're brand new to the channel,
James Gunn is getting ready to announce
his full slate of DC Phase one movies
for the next few years, which includes
all the rebooted versions
of the characters.
We'll find out
who's staying, who's surviving
and who got fired, like who got the boot.
Because you can't spell reboot
without boot.
Of course
I'll do videos for all that stuff.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
I literally just posted a video
about Jason Momoa revealing
that he was not going to be fired
like he's one of the original DCU.
Snyder voice actors who will survive
the reboot and continue being Aquaman.
But on top of that,
they're also apparently going
to let him play other new characters
in live action movies. At the same time.
While he's also still playing Aquaman,
though the rumors are right.
I'll always be Aquaman,
anyone coming in and taking,
and then there might be
some other characters too.
So he seems really excited
about coming back as multiple characters.
I'll put a link for that video
at the end of this and down
in the description below.
But you also probably saw the first look
at the main villain of the Flash movie
in your feeds.
Thanks again to the toys.
We know exactly
what's going on with the main villain.
We had an idea before,
but this is quite a bit different
than what I expected
it was going to look like in the film,
and it looks like it was inspired
by a couple of comic book and big flash
TV show characters and Easter eggs.
For those of you
wondering how much DC TV stuff did
make it into the movie,
like Grant Gustin flash stuff.
In the new promo,
they confirmed that the main villain
is being referred to as Dark Flash,
not reverse Flash,
not evil Flash, but he is basically like
the evil version of Flash.
But it does confirm that Eobard Thawne
Reverse-Flash is not the main villain,
or at least right now,
as far as we know, connected
to this particular version of Dark Flash.
There are other villains in the movie,
like more obvious villains like Michael
Shannon is coming back as a multiverse
version of Zod fairies coming back in.
They're meant to be versions
of the characters
who in Michael Keaton, Batman's universe
came to this earth to conquer.
But for some reason, Henry CAVILL'S
Superman wasn't there to stop them.
It's Supergirl on this earth.
I think the idea is that it was her POV
that wound up on planet Earth,
not Henry Cavill Superman or something
happened to his pod in this universe
that caused it to not reach Earth yet.
But it sounds like Zod and Fiora aren't
the actual main villains of the movie.
It's really dark flash.
And if you look at his suit, it's
all black.
I know
that makes you think of the black flash,
but that's like a completely different
concept, completely different character.
Whereas the black Flash's suit just
looks like a black version of the suit.
This black version of the suit
looks almost organic, like he's growing
all over his body, and it looks like
his face has also been scarred.
So they did do like a final boss
version of Eobard Thawne Reverse-Flash
In a black costume like this
that looks a little bit more like this,
more organic looking, which if you haven't
read the comics, makes him
look almost exactly like a new 52 version
of the Reverse Flash.
Least concept is the same concept
as the Reverse-Flash.
The new 52, who was Iris
West, younger brother Daniel West.
He was a totally new character
created during the new 52 reboot,
and it was meant to be a new spin
on the concept of the Reverse-Flash
because they wanted to use somebody new
for Reverse-Flash who wasn't Uber Thorne
like not bringing him back
for like the billionth time.
But they did eventually bring a version
of Eobard on back in the new 52,
so they're basically taking that concept,
but also, at least
according to the official marketing,
they're not calling him
Reverse-Flash in the movie,
which is good because it leaves them room
to introduce Eobard Thawne.
Reverse-Flash in future movies,
when they eventually recast Ezra miller
and do a rebooted version
of all this stuff.
The other major change
that they're making for a dark flash
in this movie is that he's actually
a future version of alternate universe.
Barry Allen, who's become evil and twisted
like the alternate Barry
from Michael Keaton.
Batman's earth
in this, like through his use of the Speed
Force has changed his body his suit
to look like this, which is another new 52
reverse flash thing,
like they're taking the Daniel West
storyline
and giving some of that
to this alternate version of Barry.
And combining it
with a version of Flashpoint,
the whole idea with Daniel West
Reverse Flash is that he looked like this,
like his suit, his face,
his body looked like this
because of the way
the negative speed force
had physically changed his body.
It made him look more monstrous.
What they're saying about the other Barry
Allen in the trailer
is the one from Michael Keaton.
Batman's earth is it?
Main flash.
Ezra miller travels, the multiverse,
winds up on Michael Keaton.
Batman's earth.
In there he finds a younger version of
himself who hasn't become the Flash yet.
Like,
even though he looks the exact same, he's
meant to chronologically
be a younger version,
and they're going to think of him
as kind of like a kid flash in the movie
before he becomes evil.
And for a long time
Flash TV show watchers.
Some of these tropes
will feel familiar to you.
Here's the the big connection
to Grant Gustin Flash.
They're basically pulling a Savitar in
the Flash movie with this alternate Barry
Like I told you
from the beginning,
I am the future Flash.
If you didn't watch the Flash Season
three, Savitar is the Flash Comics villain
who thinks of himself as the God of speed
and used the Speed Force
in a slightly different way
than the Flash family.
He's a completely different character
in the comics in the DC TV universe.
On the Flash TV show,
they changed his backstory and said that
he was actually an evil future
version of Barry Allen, like a future time
remnant that had become evil,
like an echo from another timeline
that was created when the main version
of Barry Grant Gustin Flash
started creating a bunch of time
remnants to also fights Avatar.
This was meant to build on the concept
of the TV show version of Flashpoint,
with Barry changing the past.
It causing all kinds of dangerous
ripple effects in the future.
One of the side effects of him
doing that messing with the timelines,
was the creation of Savitar,
and it wound up being one of his alternate
future selves that had just become evil.
Sure is a nice timeline.
Be a shame if someone messed it up.
Like go right back to that original meme
because that's kind of what
they're doing in the Flash movie
with like the main Ezra miller Flash
messing with the timelines but doing it on
Michael Keaton Batman's Earth.
It sounds like the Flash movie
is just using a way simpler spin
on that concept that Savitar concept,
to explain how this alternate younger
Barry goes from being just like a
totally normal kid to becoming dark flash
and wind up fighting the mains.
I believe they're also kind of
thinking of the younger Barry Allen
as the movie's version of Kid Flash
until he turns evil.
Like you can see him
wearing this alternate homemade version
of the flash suit, like he doesn't have
the advanced one from the flash ring.
Like the main Ezra miller flash gets.
So they wind up turning one of Michael
Keaton Batman's old
Batman costumes, like repainting it
into a new flash costume.
That's why it looks so weird.
I made some references about this
in my previous flash movie videos.
Like there were a bunch of jokes
about how the neck looked super huge.
And that's
because it's like literally a Batman cowl.
They refashioned it into a flash cowl
and cut the ears off of it.
Sounds like the main Ezra miller
Barry Allen Flash is responsible
for this younger Barry Allen
becoming the flash in his universe.
And whatever he does through those actions
and whatever happens with Michael,
Shannon, Zod and Farah, it just leads
to this younger Barry going
completely twisted and evil in the future,
and it's meant to be their spin
on a flashpoint story,
like the whole idea of Ezra miller's
Flash, learning
that he can't alter the past.
Like he just has to learn
to accept certain things.
You can't change everything, even
if you can change time during the movie.
That also goes back to him
wanting to change his mother's death,
like wanting to go back into the past
to stop her from dying.
And that's core flash
point from the comics.
The real question with the reboot
now, though, is
what's going to happen to this alternate
evil future version of like the dark flash
in this alternate universe?
Do they wind up stopping him?
Do they wind up reversing the changes
of the timeline so that he's never created
in the original flashpoint story?
The whole resolution to the story is
that it's just one time
like it's one single universe. It's
not a multiverse story.
The main version of Barry learns
that Eobard Thorne had been trying
to trick him into altering the timeline,
leading to the destruction
of the entire world.
So the main Barry realizes
that he has to go back in time
and stop himself from changing the past.
His mother still wound up dying and
he has to live with the tragedy of that.
But the rest of the world
winds up being safe in present day.
There've been some weird rumors about them
potentially bringing Ezra miller back
in future movies,
even though I think we all assume
that he's going to be recast
because he's become such a liability
to the studio,
they could only say
at the end of the movie that they think
that they reversed the changes to the
timeline on Michael Keaton Batman's Earth,
but the evil dark forces, the evil future
version of this alternate Barry winds up
escaping into the multiverse,
and that still played by Ezra miller,
like he's playing both roles.
So if Ezra miller comes back,
it could potentially just be as the dark
evil flash.
Personally,
with the entire reboot of the universe,
I think it's just easier for them
to use the flashpoint story to say that
when they write things like
when they try to fix the timeline
at the end of the movie, they just fix it
in a way that still causes
like a couple of minor changes and things.
You just quote unquote,
a little bit different in the future.
And that's how they explain James Gunn's
rebooted version of the DC Universe.
Originally, it seemed like they were going
to recast all the Justice League actors,
so it would have been a little bit easier
to use Flashpoint to wrap all that up.
But then Jason Momoa came out
and was like, Hell no, nobody's recasting
me, I'm coming back.
All I want.
Also coming back is multiple characters.
Originally they did have Henry Cavill
Superman Cameos and Gal Gadot,
Wonder Woman cameos in The Flash movie.
It sounds like those have been taken out.
I've talked about this in the past
just because they're rebooting everything.
They don't want to have a bunch of scenes
that tease future movies
that they're not going to pay off
because they're playing
for the next ten years of DC
Movies are completely different.
He replied to someone's post
a couple of days ago
saying that the month wasn't
completely over because he had promised
that he would announce his DC Phase
one slate before the end of the month.
Hopefully
he doesn't wait till like the last
possible minute on January 31st
to make his announcement.
Of course
I'll do videos for all that stuff.
Make sure you enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss any of that stuff.
Click here to watch Jason Momoa tease
Aquaman two and what's going to happen
with his other brand new DC character
that he's going to play,
confirming a bunch of theories.
And speaking of Snyderverse, click here
for that new Zack Snyder Rebel Moon
Trailer video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.